married couple and their little daughter
live in terror of the neighbor's dog and
things take an unexpected turn when the
dog decides to bite the girl so today on
cinema recapped i'll show you human
animals
the film begins with fabiol and roy who
are quietly eating their lunch while
talking to their daughter theresa later
fabiola was about to go out with her
daughter when suddenly a dog scares them
and causes teresa to start crying
meanwhile roy was working when one of
his neighbors named chava asks him to
stop working and to play basketball with
him he agrees and they both play and
have a drink let me see fabiola coming
back from the store and royce sees that
she bought a repellent for dogs and he
tells her that she's been overreacting
they were about to argue but at that
moment the neighbors arrive bringing a
vegan dessert for them and also inviting
them to dinner that night however the
couple says that their daughter is
afraid of the dog and the neighbors ask
if they can leave the girl at home but
the couple says no because she is still
too young
chava says that he will lock up the dog
although her partner named anna doesn't
seem happy with the idea at dinner will
they wait for the food to be ready chava
begins to talk to the couple about how
he met his wife on a pig farm he also
tells them that he became an animal
protection activist because in that farm
he saw how animals were mistreated a lot
cutting off their ears tails and
removing their teeth without anesthesia
they start eating when suddenly the dog
comes out of where he was supposedly
locked up and scares the girl so fabiola
gets angry and she along with her
partner and the girl leave the next day
the girl was playing in the yard when
she notices that one of her toys
disappeared she goes to look for it and
realizes that the neighbor's dog has it
and he's biting it so she tries to hit
him with a rock but the dog bites her on
the arm then fabial arrives and takes
the dog off her by rubbing him with the
dog repellent at the hospital they tell
the parents that the girl will have to
go to therapy to regain the mobility of
the arm at that moment the neighbors
arrive so fabiola gets angry and
complains about the damage that the dog
caused to her daughter but the neighbors
say that the girl attacked the dog first
and that the repellent also hurt him so
it begins a great discussion that leads
nowhere then rod contacts an old friend
who is a lawyer to help him get rid of
the animal but the lawyer gets
authorization to euthanize the dog this
makes her think about whether what he
did was right or wrong that night
there's a blackout in the house and the
next day when the technician repaired it
he told them that the incident could
have been caused the couple then goes to
ask a neighbor if they notice something
strange at night and he tells them that
he saw anna in their house that night so
the couple complains to these neighbors
chava who is at home apologizes for what
happened saying that his wife anna has
not been feeling very well lately and
also tells them that they are going to
move soon
however when they return home roy
realizes that someone has blown the
tires of his car at night the family
begins to hear strange noises outside so
roy decides to go take a look leaving
fabiola and the girl at home royce
starts looking everywhere until he
reaches the neighbor's house meanwhile
fibial answers the phone and the lawyer
tells fabiola that the neighbors are
actually using false names so they must
be careful with them then fabiol decides
to take a knife and take her daughter to
a different room roy keeps looking at
the neighbor's house in the dark when
suddenly he sees the neighbor with a dog
mask he stabs roy in the knee causing
him to full tibial was locked in the
room with her daughter when suddenly
someone tries to enter but she defends
herself by stabbing the stranger's hand
she gets scared for a moment but then
she hears her husband so she opens the
door to let him in they realize that
they don't have a cell phone with them
so they decide all together to go down
to find the phone however they run into
the neighbors who are wearing dog masks
they say they want justice and that it
will be tit for tat so just as they lost
their dog they will lose their daughter
theresa then roy asks fabiola to escape
with the girl while he is trying to stop
the neighbors the neighbors make another
wound on his other foot so that he can
no longer walk and tie him
tibial and the girl run to another
neighbor's house and knock the door
however since there's no answer fabiola
tells her daughter tenta threw a hole in
the door and when fabiola was also about
to enter she's grabbed by chava who ties
her by the neck and drags her he takes
her back to the house with roy and anna
stays watching them while chava goes to
look for the girl at the neighbor's
house but when he gets home he realizes
that the neighbor is there with the girl
so he asks him to hand over the girl and
he will not do anything to him the
neighbor refuses and fights chava
hitting him and knocking him unconscious
on the ground
meanwhile anna gets impatient because
her husband doesn't return so she
decides to go look for him then roy asks
fabiola to escape by herself because he
is injured and cannot walk but fabiola
does not want to leave him there the
neighbor and the girl were escaping when
suddenly on appears and cuts the
neighbor's neck the girl runs and
manages to escape then anna goes to look
for her husband and wakes him up asking
him to go watch the couple as she goes
to look for the girl chava goes to roy
and fabiola and they ask him to stop all
this nonsense but chava tells them he
wants justice and then shows them some
things he prepared like an electrocution
machine and dog repellent because he
plans to make the girl suffer the same
pain that the dog suffered then roy asks
sava ten tie him just to have a drink
and he agrees however roy manages to
start a fire and burn chavez's face in
response chava turns on the shocking
machine and shocks roy to death at that
moment on arrives with the girl and
looks at everything that happened so she
begins to scold chava for having killed
roy because she wanted the couple to
suffer first when they saw the girl die
anna goes to heal chava in another room
and fabiola takes the opportunity to
tell her daughter to untie her at that
moment on arrives and fabiola hits her
with a bottle knocking her down tibial
takes her daughter to a room to hide
while chavez discovers what they did to
his wife when he sees his wife on the
ground chava takes a knife and goes in
search of fabiola and the girl but when
he finds them fabiola defends herself
with a hook sticking it in his neck
fabial and the girl were about to leave
the house the fabiola decides to return
to finish killing chava who was bleeding
on the floor
when she was coming back to the car she
realizes that anna was no longer on the
ground so she gets scared and run to
look for her daughter but she and the
vehicle were no longer there
we later see the fabiola contacted the
police but they couldn't find her
daughter let me see on in a new place
with a new appearance who treats the
girl as if she were a dog locked inside
her house the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
the recaps of the best horror movies my
name is tc and i'll see you in the next
video bye